in Benin West Africa the bessel rebe
tribe has lived the same way for
hundreds of years
one key to the tribe sense of identity
is ritual scarification in this arduous
bloody process the scars left by cuts
form intricate designs the Besser rebe
scar the face to mark the start of
childhood and the abdomen to signify
adult here in the village of tacky sare
Nodame Anju is preparing to leave his
childhood behind soon slices in the skin
of his stomach will officially initiated
into adulthood
whenever my friends and I are together
always cry baby and now I went to show
him that I tune the bessarovia initiate
young man into adulthood every four
years mangu missed the last ceremony
because he was in Nigeria working on a
farm the ones who are already certified
when they see me now they don't accept
knowledge in society the village
blacksmith Nadal Felix will perform the
scarification using scrap metal and an
ancient bellows feelings will make a
knife to use on mangu its initiation day
mangu fortifies himself with millet
porridge and his mother offers a quick
sip of homemade alcohol
why should I lie down like this yes as
his family was on mangu receives the
first cuts the process will take nearly
an hour in a nearby village preparations
are underway for the facial
scarification of a child nuts awfully
according to best arre be custom once a
child has been weaned from his mother he
is ready for scarification Philippe's
mother coos on cotton pay considers the
tradition a vital step she believes the
ritual will please our ancestors spirits
and protect Philippe from happy because
it is and she is only going to cry no I
can console him
Philippe's head has been partially
shaved so the scarification can reach
the very top of his forehead by
tradition the ceremony must take place
on flat ground beneath the tree with the
child resting on a bed of fresh leaves
[Music]
the blacksmith begins cutting with the
village elders looking on the blacksmith
spends some 30 minutes
edging designs into the boy's face the
scarification is done though coos Anka
stayed with her son her husband couldn't
take it I went away I was afraid to see
my child leading to fight infection
coos Anka covers Philippe's wounds with
a salve made from the leaves of the
shade tree Philippe scars have initiated
him as a child of the best Arriba in the
other village Mongoose ordeal is nearly
over his scarified peers arrived to Hale
as the boys honor the ancestral spirits
singing to celebrate their friends
harder a man
very very high didn't know if I was
going to be able to make it through the
lines I wanted I told him to give me the
same as that he has on his chest
milk mill the undoing I told him he went
to New England by enduring the pain of
scarification mangu has proved his
manhood and cemented his bond with the
community